[Music]
[Applause]
kelly slater friend of the show he's in
the bracket challenge right now he is in
second place but he has duke ucla
arizona in kansas he has ucla beating
arizona in the national title game well
he doesn't pick games for a living he
still serves for a living just turned 50
still the best
surfer in the world he and tony hawk
sean white were at the oscars to present
a tribute to the 60-year anniversary of
the james bond franchise and kelly joins
us on the program good morning kelly on
a scale of one to ten
how nervous were you at the academy
awards
not that nervous i don't know maybe uh
five maybe average really
well did it help having tony and sean
there with you
yeah probably so
i think it did i i i didn't think too
much about it you know we're a little
bit
of a fish out of water at that thing so
it wasn't um
i don't know i've been more nervous at
speaking at school and you know when i
was in high school talking to people in
front of class or something you know who
was the coolest person you met sunday
night
coolest person i met
jeez
um
i went up and tried to say try to say hi
to snoop dogg because i met him a long
time ago he kind of big time me so i
didn't get to say hi to him um
i love snoop dogg though um
queen latifah i love her she she was
sitting next to us at the show and she's
always been really nice i met her about
20 years ago but she's she's great
all right so where were you
when the slap happened
well i was getting ready to run on stage
because
i didn't like him making fun of bald
people
[Music]
well were you ready to go on stage and
slap chris rock is that what you're
saying kelly
no i was kind of um
you know
unfortunately i was i was sitting off
the side and i wasn't really sort of
paying attention i looked over and kind
of saw will walking up there and i
thought it was part of the skit
and um
so i you know i don't know there's
three four hours of you sitting there so
you're not paying attention to
everything that's happening
and i was sort of looking down and i
heard the slap and i looked up and i was
like whoa what just happened and the
whole place went like
and everyone kind of went quiet
and then will kept cussing and yelling
at him and you could hear every single
word you know it was like really awkward
and
i think a lot of people started kind of
laughing at first because they thought
it was a skit and then realized right
away it was not the skit but it's you
know it was really confusing i think for
everyone really uncomfortable and um
just a very strange moment but
look people are
you know all of us are have our faults
all of us have our moments
of good and bad and
i think
for whatever reason it was just one of
those
moments that didn't go to
to plan and um i'm i'm sure
i'm sure they're both really embarrassed
about it and maybe sad about it and it's
a
i i can see both sides of it i felt kind
of worse for chris rock at the time but
i i can see both sides of the equation
could you hear the slap
yeah and that's why i looked back up and
went whoa
heard that stockton slapped you know
and then what but then they go to
commercial break and everybody's
consoling will smith and jada is anybody
checking on chris rock who got smacked
well we don't
exactly know when all the breaks are
happening you know you
uh
i guess well they do give us a little
time thing on the tv so you you have an
idea but
um
i don't know everyone was kind of taught
looking up and watching it but then also
like talking to themselves and
obviously the moment the night was going
to be about will smith because
everyone's like oh it's his time he's
going to win his oscar and
so
it's just a
there's just an unfortunate event but
there's some great memes
i know
who were you sitting with
um i was sitting next to between tony
hawk and sean white and then queen latif
was next to us
travis barker and
and courtney kardashian were behind us
we were playing in this little bubble
samuel jackson's off the side so i was
kind of watching samuel
l jackson to see what he was going to do
but
um i don't know it was just a gosh man
what what a strange
uh moment in time you know was travis
barker making out uh the entire time
not with me no with his girlfriend no
no not
no was he no they weren't no they were
cool they were cool i've known travis a
long time so we were chatting a little
bit and um
uh he actually israel i thought it was
really interesting because he played
he he was kind of the house band and he
played uh drums
for reba mcintyre song
and um
i really when i saw him up there i
thought this is going to be interesting
because i don't
know what what
you know how many different styles of
music he plays i'm sure he can play
anything but
if his drumming fit super well and was
really interesting behind reba mcintyre
so that's something to take and take
into account when you watch that
he's kelly slater uh joining us on the
program i was wondering you know when i
saw you and tony and sean
the physical toll of skateboarding
snowboarding and surfing how would you
rank those with the physicality of the
toll it takes on your body
uh i think skating is probably the worst
and then
yeah i was talking to tony and sean
about that how
surfing we
we get a lot of ankle
knee injuries occasionally some back
injuries but
every fall you're on water right so
it's not so bad then now and then you
hit the reef and get cut so we get a lot
of scrapes and cuts
but um
they don't drown
those guys don't drown
so that's like we we have a whole
different we kind of have like a lot of
small injuries and then we have this
whole other level then you just skip the
middle ground and you go to drowning is
there
is there a strategy to not drowning
well there's a lot of cross training
that guys do
and girls do
in the pool and in the ocean
breath work free diving
understanding
how close you are to that when you do
classes you can figure out how close you
are to that level because a lot of times
you'll hear a million surfers say god i
almost drowned this one time and like i
don't know if you actually almost
drowned i feel like i've come close a
couple times to getting to that pass out
stage but
um can you relax is that the best thing
to do you have to relax you have to you
have to in the middle of a maelstrom
like of chaos you have to learn how to
relax and that's the whole idea is
once you do some training around that
and you deal with fear you start to
understand that when fear comes up your
heart races your oxygen burns quicker
um you have to override that you have to
override the software in your brain it's
it's that fear button that's telling you
to be scared you have to override that
and trust that
the calmer you are the longer you're
gonna last and the better chance you
have coming up and then just being fine
uh
but
you can quickly get yourself in a panic
and uh that's why the cross training
like in the in a pool going in a pool
what we do is we do these um these are
these training methods where
when it starts you get in the pool and
you swim as fast as you can to the other
side underwater on one breath like you
know a 25 meter pool or whatever
and when you get to the other side you
start taking your vitals your heartbeat
how many strokes it took you to get
there etc how long and how long the swim
was and then once you start to learn a
method to a more
efficient swimming uh
underwater and being calmer you do it
again you test your time which will take
you like twice as long you check your
heartbeat
heartbeat which will be somewhere
between a third and a half of what it
was
and uh
everything just drops down if you're
more calm and you do it in a more
efficient way and you you learn to do a
certain stroke where you you do one big
stroke and kind of flutter kick your
feet and you let your momentum glide you
through the water and when you do that
you
i went from i don't know say 12 or 15
strokes underwater to get from one side
to the other down to four
i can do a whole pool in four strokes
like an olympic-sized pool
um
and
i could probably do
triple or more the amount of time
underwater if i'm calm
well plus uh you know tony hawk and sean
white don't have to worry about sharks
rarely they have to worry about sharks
in their lineup line of work right
yeah or more big locals that don't like
you being there you know stuff like that
what do you mean big locals
oh like when you you show up at some
surf spot somewhere in the world there's
some big grumpy guy who surfed every day
of his life and
even if you show up
uh it doesn't matter waves are more
important than people in in our world
can you just show up at any beach though
and and people won't bother you
um
no not necessarily
there's a
there's just a funny protection
mechanism that happens at good ways
around the world most you know 99 of
places i show up i'd be fine and people
be happy to surf with me or whatever or
any of the pros
people they know in the surf world but
there are some places where they just
don't want you because
they like what they have and and that's
what's important to those people and
that's totally understandable imagine
some guy that is going to bring undue
notice to your neighborhood showing up
you know what i mean it's really kind of
that thing it's not different it's just
kind of human nature well they're
territorial because this is our spot we
don't want it to become famous we don't
want exactly you know yeah this influx
of of surfers there
yeah do you miss it do you miss playing
team sports did you miss that
growing up i played oh no i played team
sports i played football basketball
baseball i actually loved it i really
liked baseball i was i really liked
playing in the field and um i loved
football i was i was crazy about
football like a fanatic about football
as a kid and
i played uh defensive safety and uh nose
guard nose tackle and um
yeah but i was like 10 at the time but i
loved it and i was actually i was small
but i was fast and i was strong i could
actually sort of sneak through the line
and get a few sacks so that was really
fun to me
if you could uh
change places with any other athlete
like if i said you could have tom
brady's career
or you could have yours
i'd have mine
how come
i i just think what i do is
the most fun thing in the world i love
surfing more than anything although i i
really admire tom i what he's done has
been amazing and i'm a fan
i grew up a bucks fan from the time i
was i was born it was the only team i
was a fan of i
uh
when i was a little kid it was like
ricky bell and leroy selman and doug
williams and uh
you know that whole thing and the
creamsicle uniforms back then
yeah and i i that was really my only
team and and it's you know we never did
good we lost hope for a long time and
then i heard rumor that tom was going to
play for tampa bay in
about a week or two before he announced
it i messaged him and
i said tell me it's true and we can just
jump back on this with this
fan bandwagon and he just sent me a
smiley emoji back and about a week or
two later he announced it and
i've been
we've been real happy back in florida
let's say that did you keep it secret
your correspondence
yeah i didn't tell anybody that that's
you know
yeah you could have been adam schefter
you could have broken the news you could
have been nfl insider and world's
greatest surfer
in that order
no i think look when if you if you have
a line of communication with somebody
about something that's this trustworthy
you keep that and um i i thought it was
just nice to get that
message back you know i know tom
probably is dealing with a lot of
pressure and a lot of rumors and stuff
so
it's fun to just have that banter with
people in the sports world or whatever
well uh
congrats and uh your bracket's doing
okay but you got ucla beating arizona in
the national title game so that's that's
probably not going to work out
but if it does if you then you're going
to win
you're going to win but uh these things
always come down to this one wild card
pick you know yeah yeah i know that we
do this in the surf world we have a uh
we have a fantasy surf league a couple
different surf leagues and surfing and
um
just just to be uh
just to be fair i always pick myself i
never pick my i never unpick myself
that way it looks like i'm throwing
heats for that you know 150 dollar prize
at the end of the week that my friends
give out
you know i would hate to be pete rose in
this circumstance wow
wow
what's your schedule the rest of the day
i'm just curious you know the life of a
surfer here
i'm actually
literally looking at the surf on my
phone right now to see if it's going to
be any fun today but uh
[Music]
um what am i going to do at 11 o'clock
have a meeting i'm working on a sandal
with a shoe company called the walking
company
so we're gonna meet and see the first
version of our sandal and then
i don't know tomorrow i'm going to tpi
titleist performance institute with a
friend and go get some clubs fitted for
him
this week i'm just getting my surfboards
together my equipment together surfing a
little bit
um but let's say you had that meeting at
11 o'clock but those waves start to kick
up can you bail on that meeting
it's happened
it's happened before
you might make up an excuse that you
have to bail on a meeting like that yeah
yeah that's when you know i'm like oh my
mom's really sick
yeah uh 11 time world surf league
champion and uh great to talk to you uh
thanks for joining us as always kelly
dan great to talk to you again and uh
all the best to you man we still we
still have the surfboard in here i don't
want to take it out and use it because
it's got your autograph on it so well if
you do just film it please film it if i
go out yes correct
oh it could end poorly
maybe
it could end like this uh
like these fantasy picks when my ucla
team beats arizona and you guys are just
i know could be the miracle miracle win
thank you kelly all right that's kelly
slater he's pretty good at surfing but
wouldn't trade places with tom brady